ich meine ich freu mich auch nicht wie
viel du mit deinem 400 euro job im café
verdienst oder nicht sollte jetzt ein
kleiner witz sein ding 400 euro job aber
war es nicht mehr so etwas klappt das
willkommen bei neuen video jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon am titel gesehen es
geht heute mal um so viel verdiene ich
mit youtube blabla allerdings nicht so
wie es jetzt in letzter zeit ziemlich
viele user gemacht haben so auf denen so
ja so und so kann man mit youtube geld
verdienen produktionen mache ich
eigentlich nicht und ich habe natürlich
auch so 130.000 euro verlangt faceman
ganz einfach abgelehnt weil es hat mich
halt nicht so angesprochen so hey leute
ich will da heute wirklich schon ganz
okay was heißt ganz anderes thema also
ich will so eine sache mal so ansprechen
dem ich was dieses thema angeht also mit
youtube geld verdienen das regt mich so
auf eine scheiße ich denke mir so dinger
jungs habt ihr keinen oder was heißt
jungs generell so warum wollt ihr das
immer wissen so versteht ihr ich weiß
auch ganz genau dass dieses video jetzt
weil ich heute den titel schreibe so
viel verdiene ich genau deswegen macht
es mehr klicks als meine anderen videos
zu in den ersten zwei tagen weil zeit
wirklich so viele leute interessiert und
viele verstehen gar nicht dass man mit
youtube auch geld verdienen kann
beziehungsweise wirklich so viel geld
verdienen kann mit dieser wenigen arbeit
weil das ist ja überhaupt keine arbeit
was wir machen ich mein so jeden tag ein
video was ist das bitte hallo ich gehe
auf jeden tag sechs stunden in die
schule und kriegt dafür kein geld ja
klar aber ich bin auch sechs bis neun
stunden am tag in die schule gegangen
und habe nebenbei noch das hier gemacht
und warum sollte man dafür kein geld
kriegen also leute was mich wirklich so
übertrieben aufregt ich stelle euch
jetzt einfach mal so eine situation das
wirklich so oft und ich bin auf
irgendeiner party oder so von freunden
keine ahnung so die hälfte kann ich
andere hälfte kenne ich nicht und dann
kommt immer immer drei vier mal pro
abend dieses gespräch zustande auf
dieser seite ist jetzt irgendwer den ich
nicht kenne der mich anspricht bzw
mit dem man ins gespräch kommt und auf
dieser seite bin ich also passt mal auf
so läuft das eigentlich immer ab ich
weiß nicht woher aber irgendwie kommst
mir ein bisschen bekannt von jojo das
kann schon sein so eigentlich machst du
nicht irgendwie so youtube-videos oder
sowas ja genau deshalb komme ich dir
vielleicht auch ein bisschen bekannter
ist wahrscheinlich war das video geguckt
oder so jamann ich war echt heftig
überrascht was ihr schon über 100.000
abonnenten oder so das ja schon eine
ganz schöne menge
hat sich also ergeben so ganz cool
eigentlich mein hobby und so bis im
beruf auch ich habe auch jetzt letztes
wieder ein video von dir gesehen echt
richtig cool danke welches meinst du
denn vor keine ahnung das war irgendwie
sowas mädchen abends vorm schlafen
machen oder so das hat er glaube ich
auch ziemlich viele aufrufe und ich habe
mir so die rag gedacht warum gucken so
was weißt du so ich mag diese team zwar
gerne denke mir das zwar auch manchmal
aber du musst doch gerade noch gesagt
befand ist es cool
ach so ja das war jetzt nicht so gemeint
also du hast auch hier das video war
ganz cool aber du hast auch coole videos
so noch ja ist ja auch egal kommen das
war was trinkt oder so wenn der boxer
scania besser land ja klar können wir
gerne machen aber ich habe wirklich eine
frage so das muss ich jetzt mal fragen
ja fragt man kann ja damit schon richtig
viel geld verdienen oder komplett drauf
an was du machst und videos machst du
funktion man kann damit schon geld
verdienen ja wo ich hoffe ich kann nicht
so etwas fragen aber sag mal ganz
ehrlich so unter uns ich sag's doch
keinen ich schwöre ich sage das kann wie
viel verdienst du so ohne scheiß leute
das ist wirklich immer das gleiche immer
fällt ein gespräch so anwendet wenn mich
irgendwann fragt so jo du machst doch
diese videos und so finde ich eigentlich
ganz cool
am ende kommt immer die frage wie viel
verdienst du damit warum ist das so ich
meine ich freu mich auch nicht wie viel
du mit deinem 400 euro job im café
verdienst oder nicht sollte jetzt ein
kleiner witz sein ding 400 euro job aber
war es nicht mehr so ja leute und am
anfang habe ich mich wirklich noch so
auf diese diskussion eingelassen und
dann vielleicht ein bisschen erzählt
wenn man produktionen macht dann
verdient man vielleicht mal ein bisschen
mehr als so nur durch klicks oder
vielleicht doch irgendwie da und da war
was hier meinen instagram post oder
sonstwas wo dann kommt man ganz
vielleicht aber auch irgendwelche zahlen
an dem er sich so leicht orientieren
kann jo ich krieg so pro 1000 klicks
keine ahnung 50 60 cent ist total
unterschiedlich manchmal sind sie auch
viel mehr aber ich weiß dass viel
weniger das ist ja alles nicht mehr so
unbekannt dass es so ist und dann gibt
es auch wirklich leute die zücken ihr
handy und rechnen dass aus wie viel ich
letzten monat verdient haben oder so die
denken dann sie können das kurz
ausrichten
da denk ich mir dann immer ist das
gerade ein ernster genießt man hier
lieber bisschen den armen anstatt uns
über irgendwelche gelder zu unterhalten
oder so und meistens ende das gespräch
dann so hey so viel damit fange ich
morgen auch an und dann wenn diese
person an
macht drei videos merkt auch das ist ja
doch ganz schön viel zeitaufwand ich
habe pro video grad 1 3
die klicks ich höre auf und das finde
ich echt so heftig schade ich meine
alles hat man angefangen auf youtube da
ging es nur um den spaß da konnte man
nicht mal geld verdienen ich habe auch
angefangen mit youtube da war ich zwölf
oder so mit irgendwelchen scheiß
langweiligen videos die eigentlich kein
interessiert haben aber ich habe
angefangen weil es mir spaß gemacht hat
und ich war immer damit jetzt so viel
geld verdienen kann ich mein ich habe
auch mega viel arbeit reingesteckt auch
wenn ich wirklich überhaupt keine zeit
hatte halt damit irgendwas zu gucken hat
und ja dann ist es doch okay wir machen
mit geld verdient oder nicht und da muss
man sich auch nicht fragen jungs so viel
ist dass ich mein okay wir reden jetzt
nicht von irgendwelchen summen im
fünfstelligen bereich so aber es ist
wirklich man kann gut ja ich komme gut
mit klar so ich habe ja immer gesagt so
ob 105000 kann man davon schon so
alleine leben wenn man es gut macht kann
man auch davon alleine leben aber hört
einfach auf mich die fans zu stellen wie
viel ich verdiene man was geht euch das
an ganz ehrlich ich kämpfe mich nicht
mal also das war jetzt nicht an euch
darauf ausgerichtet die gerade das video
schauen sondern die leute die mich halt
so fragen die ich nicht mag eine so im
reallife wisst ihr die halt auch hier
wohnen oder so so in die richtung mehr
ich wollte jetzt nicht euch damit
ansprechen uhr so also nur halt so 000
000 1 prozent von den leuten gerade das
video so viele erstmal dazu wenn's euch
gefallen hat wirklich mega freuen wenn
ihr nach oben da lass diarra slapshot
ins heim als eingebildet schreib doch
mal eure meinung zu gastgeber und in die
kommentare hier oben links abonniere
nicht vergessen um dazu verpassen
jetzt weiter mit einem letzten check
listen ab das war keine ahnung was
einfach abschenken wir sehen uns da man
dann am donnerstag nicht mal wieder von
seiner schönen tag noch kies